how's the resume can't touch me oh maybe
you can well what are you gonna do about
it
we are back what this game he has not
even updated these oh yeah man in yeah
yeah wait hey man you want a massage
it's free it's kidding it cost an axe
and your life like this what can I do
for you to massage me what just happened
all right write 5 if you kill it price
ray rate 5 best map ever only I can make
love to Timmy that's right [ __ ] no
one's gonna [ __ ] you now oh maybe they
will damn it what he's fine
what the [ __ ] i castrated him whoo ha ha
rainbow fall oh wow I never seen one of
these before
step 5 suck my ass senpai that's right
hang on you stupid you leave me how dare
you leave me your [ __ ] I'm coming for
you you will pay
why do I even bother bit trying to be a
father when my son is such a lame ass
[ __ ] your son of a me dammit
why do you have to be my son that's the
problem
go to hell [ __ ] yeah that's how we deal
with Anna put a pot down [ __ ] it's all
you and me back ah ah my legs
I don't need legs - [ __ ] it's going too
fast
Oh back call me sometime bike all right
what do we got here if you made it you
are gone ha front flip
whoopsie-daisy is disappointing as your
mom's nipples that's how it's done
good job boy you're proud of me now dad
I'll be proud when you're [ __ ] dead
dad I ended don't talk back to me we go
front flip look at that [ __ ] boy look at
this [ __ ] boy I complete maps without
any [ __ ] limps that's a real badass
people do it this is how it start on my
seal oh oh yeah that were you doing too
busy being a little [ __ ] huh bottle
runs hey still there they [ __ ] really
you're kidding me no damn it
oh yes ah finally I'm free from the
devil harpooned meso Brogan mess me
[ __ ] makes me [ __ ] miss me [ __ ] shut
shut your damn mouth you will have no
dinner tonight Tex
oh god what I tell you my penetrating
your dad [ __ ] me
oh yeah oh that feels good stop it stop
this we're going we got a completist
[ __ ] deaf how do i purchase this land
from this point there we go alright I'm
fine I'm fine like that you can't touch
me oh maybe you can but what are you
gonna do well gotta go fast
dad gotta go fast shut your damn mouth
get it shut up oh thank god he died yes
ma'am I can't wait to see some naked
ladies shut your damn mouth if you like
boys you like boys damn it tell me you
like boys that's right I love Bates
alright let me get back on that bike ah
that's right you think you can escape
from me no one escapes me ah I'm a table
shut your damn mouth you see this fine
ass [ __ ] table it's better than
anything you've done with your life I
protect you boy you're welcome ha ha you
got George look at this table [ __ ] dad
do you love me yes so much sorry I
thought that was Satan this is not what
I ordered
I want a fresh ABS [ __ ] watermelon
and I want it now back massage I love it
what a meal on my life is in danger what
I'm alone do something stop just want to
[ __ ] the water melone it said too much
stress Naruto whether you're doing Adam
not at all not at all not at all what am
I doing with these people na da da what
the [ __ ] is this what is this [ __ ] not
at all what the [ __ ] what it what is
this what am i what happened to happy
wheels no thanks I'm good
how legs burn all right that was a good
ol happy wheels wasn't it it's fun to
read whiz it every once in a while but
yeah if you want to watch more check out
the playlist and I will see you Bros as
always in the next one
stay awesome bros